today we are going to take Chad GPT and
it will be given a Stern talking to yes
we will try to help it to learn from its
own mistakes and do better can it well
let's see together but first and
foremost how do we do this well these
large language model assistants can
typically be improved from the inside by
reprogramming them however not in this
paper here is a crazy idea let's try to
improve it by reprogramming it from the
outside instead with linguistic feedback
yes get this it will get a Stern talking
to now I hear you asking doctor that is
crazy how do we do that well here is an
example first we ask it a history
question and we get an answer that is
incorrect now we ask the AI to reflect
on its mistakes and now it learns that
the answer should have been a series of
Wars not just one war and now with this
in mind we can ask it again and Bam
there we go and this concept works for
decision making programming and
reasoning style questions as well that
is fantastic but how much of an
improvement can we expect using this
technique well when running open AI
human eval data set which is a test with
more than one 50 programming problems
these problems are handwritten to make
sure the AI cannot have seen these
problems before so how does it do wo
look at that suddenly it is now the best
performing AI model we go from 80% to
91% accuracy that is a huge Improvement
If This Were GPT 4.5 that would have
been a reasonable result and we didn't
need need to pop the hood all we needed
to do here is ask it nicely to
essentially write a journal and learn
from past mistakes how cool is that in
his amazing science fiction novels Isaac
azimov wrote about Robo psychologists
scientists who were called when a robot
was malfunctioning to find out what is
going on in the brain of this little Ai
and he wrote this about 73 years ago and
today here we are the the first Robo
psychologists are appearing in our real
world how incredible is that what a time
to be alive now in the meantime Chad GPT
and GPT 4 also have some new really cool
applications for instance I was stunned
to find out that not every one of you
fellow Scholars know code interpreter
now also known as Advanced Data analysis
this can use Python Programming to solve
your tasks and even takes file up
uploads I love seeing how diligently it
writes code when I ask it something this
is a super simple example Monti Carlo
integration my job here is essentially
to direct the work of this little Ai and
make sure to check it thoroughly or wait
a second what if I just ask it to test
itself H it gives some nice proposals
for me to do wait a second how about you
do all of these little Ai and I am
absolutely loving how it is going to
town and checks the validity of its
solutions from several different angles
we even get a beautiful little plot of
this classic experiment this tool is an
absolute Powerhouse and I feel that as
it improves programming computers will
be available for everyone in the world
loving it this is just incredible and
don't forget this can take files from us
and it can also give files back to us
transformed thus we can even ask it for
a little movie editing or you can upload
your favorite Spotify playlist for it to
analyze it underg goes statistical
analysis and if you like explanations
better than visualizations and bar
charts you can even ask it to explain
all this in plain English how cool is
that wow so as you see cad GPT hasn't
even been out for a year and it has
improved Leaps and Bounds you can have
this incredible intelligence trained
almost on the whole internet right at
your fingertips if you're looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up app
and launch an instance and hold on to
your papers because with the Lambda GPU
Cloud you can now get on demand H 100
instances for just1 199 per hour yes
$19 and they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like Apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com slapers to sign
up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time